my name is Jean I'm 26 and interesting
thing about me I am here doing an
interview with you right now oh that is
interesting this is a great show and
you're really lucky to be here so what
makes you the most angry in this world
um I would say online selfies in the
bathrooms well what about that makes you
angry the thoughts of their behind
that person yes and the fact that you
could have moved one room over to your
bedroom right move to that bedroom
speaking of bedrooms do you want to know
what makes me the most angry play I hate
when you're making out with a girl and
she's like sucking on your neck and then
it bursts the blood vessels and it's
like I'm 26 years old baby I don't need
a hickey you know I don't know what
you're talking about
what's that over there
[Music]